good afternoon I'm Patricia around her
i'm the deputy university librarian here
at columbia and it's the real pleasure
to have an opportunity to think about
and talk about video in the context of
one research library but i think issues
that are common to many others first of
all i think it's it's important to
recognize that when we build collections
today we're building them in some very
different ways we continue to license
and purchase and acquire materials by
gift but we're also creating and
publishing materials we're organizing in
some new ways to do that here at
columbia we've brought into our larger
information services organization the
traditional University Library component
a digital library group the Center for
new media teaching and learning that
you've been working with the last two
days we're creating a new center for
digital research and scholarship that
will include an electronic publishing
arm and a copyright office so what we're
beginning to see is that the
interactions between all of these
different groups are really enriched
what we're trying to do when to talk
about a few examples of the sorts of
publications that we're beginning to
manage and look at one of them is a
fascinating collaboration as
sino-tibetan oral history project it's
being developed by a group of
documentary filmmakers working in
consultation with Columbia's east asian
institute consulting with the library's
oral history research office to to put
together a series of interviews will be
background for the documentary film with
people who were involved in the takeover
of tibet and the end product of those
interviews the actual tapes will be
deposited in our East Asian Institute so
that we've got an external group
producing research that becomes
available permanently to scholars
frontiers of science is a website that's
being developed for educators it's being
funded by the howard hughes entity
dude and it's taking a successful new
course of Columbia that's a core
curriculum course a required course for
all undergraduates it's aimed at
graduating students will be
scientifically literate Columbia's had a
long history of focusing its
undergraduates on the humanities and
some of our science faculty finally said
well wait a minute there's a lot more
that students should know when they
leave the university because this this
course has been so successful how would
use became interested in being able to
make this available to science educators
throughout the world so we've been
videotaping faculty who have been giving
these horses chosen the ones that are
undergraduates found most stimulating
and interesting would be developing
course materials around that and also a
social environment for commentary on
teaching and learning Jazz Studies
online a third of these new types of
publications follows a pattern that we
developed for Columbia International
Affairs online a political science
publication that we've been producing
for a while this is the collaboration
between Columbia's center for Jazz
Studies between our electronic
publishing group and the scent of a new
media teaching and learning it's going
to include interviews with jazz
musicians and academics it will include
interactive web-based teaching and
learning tools such as a sonic glossary
for jobs so that students will be able
to look up a word and hear and see what
it means and working papers and digital
library resources this this product
won't be open content it will be
licensed at a very modest rate because
it will have an ongoing editorial
content component and so we really need
a sustainability plan for this
and then a site that's been released for
a while an institutional history an oral
history of the carnegie corporation
we've been working with Carnegie for a
number of years to document their
philanthropic work and produced hundreds
of hours of tapes and transcripts of
interviews in in the last two or three
years they funded us to look at what
video does in terms of getting this
history and there's some very
interesting copper pieces on this
website about the difference between an
oral history interview taken as a as a
simple audio and donna's video and as
you might expect people are more
inclined to perform in front of a camera
and so you get a very different sort of
interview both of them very valuable and
we're looking with interest about and
then we heard yesterday from our
colleagues and the center about the
Harvard Columbia site you can accompany
a vaca pebbles visit to to Columbia and
last but not least the legacy acquired
collections the analog materials that
are in all our research libraries that
are deteriorating at various rates I
picked one particular collection but we
have hundreds of these in the libraries
this is a collection that we inherited
when we took over the theological
library from Union Theological Seminary
fascinating collections of speeches and
sermons and lectures by people like
Daniel Berrigan and William Sloane
coffin and the crusted cost of
rerecording this is significant we're
fortunate to have a lily grant that is
allowing us to do this but many of our
collections are still waiting for this
sort of attention
so what are we doing about the
challenges the challenge of
disseminating of storing access and
archiving and of preserving analog
collections and disseminating is
actually one of the more difficult of
these and I think not preferred to this
yesterday maybe it's true that so when
people were presented with rows and rows
of volumes that was more of a sense that
here was something they wanted to look
at I think one of our concerns with
digital information is that it's it can
be sort of hidden from students so the
building of learning and teaching
environments gives us really interesting
opportunities to reveal content in
important and valuable ways and the
digital bridges initiative that Santa Fe
New Media is developing under Mark
Phillips minutes leadership is looking
really hard and where these connections
can be made I think Peter Brantley
talked yesterday about how valuable the
librarians and research libraries are
the amount of knowledge that is in those
people and so beginning to connect that
into the development of learning
environments is is really exciting mark
also talked about the value of being
able to break apart a multimedia
publication and store and retrieve and
reuse segments of that so we're
beginning to work at Columbia with our
digital library group to develop a life
cycle approach to managing accessing and
preserving multimedia content will be
developing a process to test a
multimedia digital asset management
system and develop a methodology to
ingest this material into a long-term
digital archive and then the issue of
preserving these analog collections
we've discovered that one of the biggest
issues here is knowing what you've got
because so much of this material has
come in
collections with other materials so
we've been working for two years now in
the second year of a melon funded study
to develop a survey that can be used by
any institution that that needs to look
at what it's got in terms of audio and
video the survey tool is complete and
we'll be putting it up on the web with
with an accompanying glossary and we're
currently testing it in our own
environment we estimate we have about
35,000 to 40,000 of these objects
analogue objects about half of which
were developed through our own history
office but the other half came into
collections worth with archival personal
collections with institutional
collections and so on and they're in
varying stages of decay and we and why
you also have the melon funded project
to to look at how visual inspection and
actual listening of materials compare in
terms of predicting the disintegration
of materials lastly I wanted to just
suggest some of the areas that we would
like to see and we are seeing some
development on a national level after
hearing Marie Weston's presentation
yesterday about the British universities
film video Council I felt that I really
wanted to rewrite this slide and just
put that at the top and say we need one
of these two in the US and its really
stunned by the material that's available
to students in the UK but to to list
some of these which I think are
important the development of widely
accepted standards and best practices
for preservation quality conservation
conversion to digital formats we need
more of the services that can meet
preservation standards and we need a
more technical experts who are familiar
with older formats of earth material
we're encouraged by the movement toward
more wide development and acceptance of
metadata standards and we need more
efficient ways of generating technical
structural and administrative metadata
often the most costly part of any of
these processes we look forward to more
shared long-term digital archives
focused on audio and video content and
we need copyrights and IP laws that
support long-term preservation and
archiving and I know that's something
that's come up frequently during the
course of the two days so thank you very
much